Statues of heroes, foreboding hints at
the future, and blasts from the past.
The new trailer for "The Mandalorian" is
filled with blink and you miss it details.
With the "Star Wars" sequel trilogy wrapping up,
Lucasfilm and Disney turned their attention to
streaming in 2019. They came out of the
gate swinging with the Disney+ exclusive
"The Mandalorian," which swiftly took the
television world by storm. Not only were
audiences fascinated by the mysterious
Mandalorian bounty hunter Din Djarin,
but they couldn't get enough of his
lovable sidekick Grogu. It only made
sense that the following year, a
second batch of episodes arrived.
For Season 2, series creator Jon Favreau went
above and beyond for "Star Wars" fans. Boba
Fett returned from the grave, Cobb Vanth jumped
from print to TV, and animated icon Ahsoka Tano
finally appeared in a live-action production. He
even snuck in Luke Skywalker for good measure.
The bar is set incredibly high for Season
3, and the creators of "The Mandalorian" are
working overtime to keep viewers glued to their
screens. Following an intriguing first trailer,
a new one premiered on January 16, 2023. Here are
some of the small details you might have missed.
A locale we get quite familiar with throughout
the first season of "The Mandalorian" is
Nevarro. It serves as a refuge for bounty
hunters, thieves, and general miscreants.
The town is riddled with run-down buildings
and takes on a generally gloomy appearance.
It improves in the second season, thanks in
large part to its magistrate, Greef Karga.
Before Nevarro became a sprawling
metropolis-in-the-making, remnants
of the Galactic Empire tore it up in pursuit
of Din Djarin and Grogu. Din and his allies
did a great job running the Empire out of
town, with one character making the ultimate
sacrifice. To save everyone in "Chapter 8:
Redemption," IG-11 used its self-destruct
capability to annihilate the Imperial troops.
In the new trailer, it's clear that to honor
the assassin droid's memory, Karga has
erected a statue of IG-11 in the square.
But just because Nevarro is thriving doesn't mean
that the entire galaxy is. As the "Mandalorian"
Season 3 teaser continues, we learn that there's
trouble on the horizon. Speaking to Din Djarin,
fan favorite Captain Carson
Teva has some ominous words.
"There's something dangerous happening out there,
and by the time it becomes big enough
for you to act, it'll be too late."
What could the X-wing pilot be alluding
to? He's likely talking about the Imperial
remnant. Between Moff Gideon's desire to
use Grogu for unspecified experiments to
his development of the Darktroopers,
it's apparent there's still a lot to
be worried about. And based on what the
"Star Wars" sequel trilogy revealed,
the rise of the First Order, the
introduction of Supreme Leader Snoke,
and the return of Emperor Palpatine are close at
hand. Teva has every reason to be on his toes.
Another potential reveal also occurred in the new
trailer. As we hear Carson Teva's bleak voiceover,
we see an unknown character sitting on
a ship next to a droid. They seem to
be on a planet dominated by large
buildings and blinding lights. At
first glance, this location looks
incredibly similar to Coruscant.
Coruscant was a key location throughout
the prequel "Star Wars" trilogy. It
also featured quite prominently on multiple
animated shows, various books, video games,
and more. Most recently, it appeared
on "Andor," where Rebel leaders Mon
Mothma and Luthen Rael work to undermine
the Empire from right under its nose.
As Din Djarin attempts to reconnect with
his Mandalorian roots, it should come as
no surprise that "The Mandalorian" Season
3 is set to include several more of the
mysterious warriors. Throughout the trailer,
we see a few unrecognizable Mandalorians and
some we've seen before, such as Paz
Vizsla. The number of Mandalorians
is rivaled only by the number of droids we
see, which range from your run-of-the-mill
astromechs to protocol droids of varying color
and make. Even a few B1 battle droids show up.
A handful of them can be seen in a shot that seems
to depict a bunch of droids hanging out in a bar
or mechanic shop of some kind. These flimsy robots
were staples of the "Star Wars" prequel trilogy.
They were destroyed in droves by clones and
Jedi alike at the command of Separatist leaders.
"The Mandalorian" Season 3
premieres on Disney+ on March 1st.